merci les gars d'être avec nous
bertrand
je sais que tu es extrêmement triste un
forcément oui je me sens seule salle est
triste je trouve vraiment seul et triste
même si j'ai j'ai passé tout l'été avec
elizabeth 2 puisque jeu
j'avais une échéance qui était le 1er
septembre et je devais rendre en
manuscrit une biographie est gelée rendu
jeudi dernier et le tout dernier
chapitre le tout dernier que j'ai écrit
c'est en jour et lili bête tu seras
morte
voilà là sept jours jour pour jour et
j'ai du mal à me dire que c'est déjà
aujourd'hui même si je sais même si je
sais que ça fait 96 ans 4 mois et 18
jours précisément que le monde connaît
et elisabeth bertron
alors nous on est tous triste voilà mais
c'est vrai que voilà pourquoi toi tu es
aussi triste ce soir ce que tu peux
expliquer pourquoi est-ce que je suis
aussi triste parce que comme je
l'expliqué dans ma biographie c'est
quelqu'un comme elizabeth ii qui tout
petit me fascine et me donne cette envie
de plus tard devenir spécialiste des
têtes couronnées parce que je suis
fasciné par cette aura des là parce
qu'elle dégage par sa dignité par le
fait que peut apporter tempête elle va
toujours rester
elle va toujours tenir la barre elle va
apprendre à moderniser la monarchie elle
va devoir aller en voir des vertes et
des pas mûres elle va elle va vraiment
elle va vraiment inscrire cette
institution millénaire dans le 21e
siècle alors aujourd'hui c'est un
véritable tremblement de terre tout le
monde ne parle que de ça qu'est ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
entendu plein de choses on a entendu que
la reine elizabeth ii était en fait
décédé à 16 heures voilà qu'ils arrivent
et qu'ils attendaient l'arrivée de deux
de ses enfants ont normalement être
plein de choses quelle est la vérité si
on remonte dans le temps donc mardi elle
reçoit nice 13 la nouvelle première
ministre la 15e première ministre on se
rappelle que le tout premier était
wiston churchill à un autre monde en 50
2 et en effet on la trouve très fatigué
on la trouve affaibli mais ça fait un an
que j'arrête pas de vous dire l'arrêt
n'allait pas fear and là ça va encore on
apprend vraiment aussi dans la foulée
qu'elle a été mise sous assistance
respiratoire
ça on l'apprend aujourd'hui
là pour le coup à partir de ce moment là
je pense vraiment dans les premiers
informés parce que j'ai vraiment
quelqu'un allons très proches qui me dit
bah voilà assistance respiratoire ça
commence entre guillemets vraiment à se
corser à sentir mauvais et très
naïvement je dis mais non parce que
c'est une vieille dame et que voilà et
puis laura d'elizabeth ii à la suze
assistance inspirateur pour l'aider à
respirer tout simplement à londres voilà
savait déjà qu'en réalité les choses
aller on allait vers cette fin ils
éduquent table il semblerait même si
c'est pas officialisé que ce soit à
16h10 puisqu'il ya des bruits vraiment
quelques bruits qui ont fuité à propos
de 16h10 mais on a commencé à rappeler
tout le monde aujourd'hui alors comment
ça se passe pour nos téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent que moi c'est celle j'ai
envie de savoir aussi c'est elle est
décidée à 16h10 ils ont annoncé beaucoup
plus tard qu'est ce qui se passe dans
ces cas là pourquoi on voilà donc aussi
tard qu'est ce qu'on attend où on attend
que toute la famille se réunit qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est la ceinture 10 à
16h10 qu'est-ce qui se passe on en a
parlé ici donc à 16h10 précisément la
reine n'est plus donc la femme est morte
en revanche la couronne aile de mort
donc à 16h10 et une seconde le rose on
en a froid on a plus de rennes un roi le
roi charles iii alors tout cela est
parfaitement orchestré dans un code on
en a parlé ici london bridge is down
c'est donc le nom de code militaire qui
a été donné à la mort d'elizabeth ii et
une série d'étapes vont commencer ont
commencé depuis 16h10 à se mettre en
place nous on a vu par exemple quelque
chose qui nous a fortement interpellé
c'est de voir que des barrières
métalliques commencé à être dressés aux
abords de toutes les résidences royales
et que d'emblée on a demandé aux
touristes de quitter le château une
sorte de quitter le palais de buckingham
là on s'est dit voilà ça c'est les
toutes premières étapes du du london
bridge e is down nous il faut savoir que
la ville et le monde comment at on été
alertés parce que l'union jack a
commencé à descendre en berry n'a sur le
toit de buckingham palace on n'est qu'à
la quinzième vont regarder on l'a
drapeau voilà regarder le drapeau de
buckingham palace qui est en berne alors
c'est assez
incroyable de vivre ça l'atmosphère qui
était complètement figé s'est assombri
ici devant buckingham palace on l'a vu
depuis le début de l'après midi est bien
de nombreux des centaines de
britanniques sont venus afflué devant
les grilles du palais alors
forcément vous à partir de quel on vous
a dit il il ya un gros sous moi je vous
avoue que je ne vois là tout est noyé
pas possible non paf we seek baffe non
je ne sais pas quoi répondre oui oui et
non mais à un moment donné voilà il faut
il faut voir l'inéluctable et voilà
après adam qui a fait 80 saison qui a
très bien vécu en effet qui a
révolutionné comme je lui ai dit
beaucoup de choses
néanmoins ce que je voulais revenir
peut-être c'est que avant donc le
drapeau ne soit vraiment mis en berne il
y a eu une étape qui a déjà été franchie
c'est que le premier ministre en
personne donc ni stress qui est nommé
depuis mardi seulement mais a été préfet
nuit c'est la toute première étape on
prévient d'abord downing street accordé
alors avant selon même la famille il
était informé semble-t-il puisque on a
commencé à rapatrier mais normalement si
vraiment vous voulez le service
crapuleusement le code la première
ministre est censé le premier ministre
est trop court en avant le futur
monarque ça techniquement que le
protocole se met en place la france
participe entièrement à ce deuil qui va
devenir mondial on en est convaincu
puisqu'on apprend que dès ce soir la
tour eiffel ne s'illumine rappaz est que
dès demain le palais de l'elysée mais
également tous ces drapeaux en berne
alors rappelle que sans elle elizabeth
ii règne sur 150 millions de sujets à
travers le globe on parle de
l'angleterre mais il ya les choses il y
a les flancs du nord et il ya tous ces
pays du commonwealth qui eux ont été
prévenus avant que l'on ne soit nous en
avant que le grand public ne soit
informé 5 opératrice au sein même du
palais ont appelé avait comme mission
d'appeler tous les représentants de ces
pays du commonwealth qui rentrent en
deuil voilà alors partir du moment où on
se parle bertrand alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ces derniers jours parce
qu'on l'a vue mardi la reine avait
pourtant reçu la nouvelle première mine
tremblay saint louis sa prise de
fonction la voilà c'est ça la dernière
absolument oui c'est sa dernière
apparition mais fort alertés par la
tâche bleue que l'on voit sur sanaa ont
saisi ce bizarre on n'avait pas vu
encore sa tâche là au préalable mais moi
je vous avoue que la trouve pas mourante
maintenant pour une photo d'il ya deux
jours moi je la trouve pas me rends du
tout je me dis 'mon d'un coup moi mon
livre qui sort dans deux mois au couple
poivre bas banon tout compte fait il
semblerait que le lendemain donc le
mercredi elle est contracté une avc
accident vasculaire cérébral se serait
apparemment ce qui figurait sur l'homme
sur le certificat de décès qui a été
signé donc là officiellement par son
médecin qui est le docteur robertson qui
est le médecin attitré qu'elle a
lorsqu'elle séjourne tonnes en écosse ça
ça faisait partie aussi des fameuses
étape du london bridge quand un secteur
est ce que sa famille était déjà là où
ils ont dû rapatrier tous alors
asesor non pas dans si on regardait
capitule gative mans à 16 heures tout le
monde n'était pas encore harry par
exemple qui est arrivé sur le tard
n'était pas présent asesor sûr et
certain charles camilla william était à
son chevet ils sont arrivés en tout
début d'après midi il faudrait voir si
vraiment ces deux autres fils un trou
edwards
était vraiment et son épouse bref
étaient présents parce qu'ils sont
arrivés par voie diplomatique
est-ce qu'il était déjà 16 or je ne sais
plus frais que l'on vérifié alors qu'est
ce qui va se passer dans les prochains
jours parce que on a parlé du jubilé et
70 ans de règne donc la reine elizabeth
il ne rien elle a participé à ce jubilé
vous nous disiez toujours après le
jubilé
j'ai peur qu'elles attendent le jubilé
pour derrien partir ben oui absolument
j'ai à utiliser que c'est une commode
avec des tiroirs et elle décidera
elle-même le moment où elle le refermera
elle a travaillé jusqu'à mardi donc
mission accomplie jusqu'au bout dans le
fond elle a toujours eu le devoir je vis
au corps c'est quelque chose qui me qui
me fascine aussi qu'est ce qui va se
passer c'est très simple ce jour ci a
été créée terre un peu le deed mais les
funérailles auront lieu au deed puisse
disent donc maintenant dans dix jours
alors on se pose une question parce que
dans dix jours ça tombe un dimanche est
ce que vraiment ils vont vraiment
célébrer les funérailles le dimanche on
n'est pas encore certain à ce que ce
serait pas peut se poser au samedi ou
peut-être au lundi en tout cas on arrive
dans une période de deuil incroyable
plus de cinéma plus de théâtre tout cela
va nous faire une séance au parlement là
tout va être fermé tout est absolument
faire saliver nautique qui tout ça ça
reste ouvert ce ne sera vraiment que le
jour des funérailles et et ce jour est
ce que c'est ce qu'il va devenir ferrier
là bas oui alors le jour des funérailles
est vraiment fait rien ça va perdurer ou
ce sera que pour cette année
donc le férié en angleterre le jour
d'être émotionnelles est-ce que ça va
perdurer après ou pas des anneaux non
saison non dans cinq ans après en
revanche la cour tous les membres de la
cour vont prendre un deuil qui lui va
durer pendant trois mois et ça me fait
penser cyril que je ne sais pas si vous
vous souvenez lors d'une des précédentes
émissions je vous avais dit que j'avais
écrites pour front à la reine oui et il
y à deux mois jour pour jour on s'est
plus vu depuis puisque c'était des
vacances j'ai une lettre de buckingham
palace qui est arrivé à votre intention
la voilà c'est une lettre comme vous le
verrez deux guitaristes c'est vrai que
monsieur cyril hanouna et on peut
peut-être remarqué en bio la sema écrit
le document mais vous avez entre les
mains déjà le papier que vous avez entre
les mains il n'existe plus non puisque à
partir de maintenant vous êtes bien le
blason déjà à changer ou la reine
elizabeth ii n'existe plus pauvres alors
la cour désormais va avoir un courrier
liseré de noirceur marquer
officiellement qui sont tentés et ça ça
c'est ça c'est fini ça ça se sera
terminée désormais les armes que vous
voyez là vous voyez le petit on est sur
eux deux heures foyer isabelle debré
jean à elizabeth ii reine s'est terminée
le roi s'appelle désormais charles iii
alors c'est donc charger qui va devenir
lourd de rideau
du louvre
on
voulait jouer au joli et non non non
mais c'est un objet de collection mais
garder l'eau précieuse ne s'est jamais
là vous pouvez décider de l'ouvrir chez
fois c'est vrai mais c'est un beau de
qui là je ne sais pas je n'ai en tout
cas moi je peux vous dire que j'ai écris
pour vous faire connaître auprès voilà
dt 2/2 de l'appel et des équipes de la
reine en vous remerciant cyril du fait
de vous parler énormément vous avez
parlé énormément d'elisabeth 2 et je
trouvais que ça méritait d'être saluée
alors on a vu que la situation
s'aggraver tout au long de la journée
puisque la bbc à la première chaîne de
télévision britannique a interrompu ses
programmes au cours de la journée autre
signe de la gravité de la situation le
prince charles le fils et héritier de la
reine et son petit-fils le prince
william comme vous nous l'avez dit sont
allés au chevet de la reine le prince
harry mégane ils sont aussi ali alors
qu'ils étaient au royaume uni pour une
oeuvre caritative va et regardez là la
famille est arrivée en jet à on l'a vu
aujourd'hui regarder toute la famille se
rassemblent la au chevet de la reine
auprès des médecins à balmoral un oui
exactement et c'est ce qui inquiète en
fait le plus les britanniques puisque la
reine est resté à balmoral elle n'a pas
été hospitalisé mais ce n'est absolument
pas rassurant puisque de façon générale
et bien un monarque ne se fait pas
hospitalisés ce sont les médecins te
mais on a un peu l'impression justement
que ses médecins ont demandé ont tout de
toute urgence à l'ensemble de la famille
royale de se réunir au chevet de la
reine elizabeth alors sont venus donc la
nouvelle est tombée à 19h30 donc trois
heures et demie après le décès de la
reine juste qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pendant ces trois heures trente ont noté
les spectateurs parce que c'est ça que
moi j'ai envie de savoir voilà déjà qui
fait le qui constate la mort la reine
elizabeth et son docteur c'est son
médecin absolument surmédiatisée
normalement ces centres un but masquer
le médecin en chef mais là
exceptionnellement comme s'il n'était
pas en territoire anglais je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est le professeur
robertson qui a autorité lorsqu'elle est
en écosse qui va donc bel et bien actée
acté le décès est alors on dit fermer
les yeux c'est à lui que revient la
tâche de fermer les yeux d'elisabeth 2
il ya quelque chose de cocasse cyril il
y a trois jours elle a promu à la donner
en ordre l'ordre victoria qui est
vraiment un ordre prestigieux à son
directeur de la communication
donc ça va peut-être se doutait
peut-être que il allait avoir énormément
de boulot parce que là à l'heure
actuelle le directeur de la
communication de buckingham palace il a
une mission énorme hein alors accomplir
on rappelle que dans les jours qui
viennent londres va être le centre du
monde toutes les caméras du monde entier
vont étendre à quai sur la ville de
londres il n'existe déjà plus de nuitées
possible quasiment tous les hôtels
toutes les maisons d'hôtes ou est déjà
complètement pris d'assaut et pendant
dix jours on va connaître en deuil qui
au deuil planétaire on peut vraiment
dire un deuil qui n'a jamais été connu
je pense que les obsèques de diana pour
ceux qui s'en souviennent en 97 dont il
ya eu les 25 ans il ya tout juste
quelques jours c'était une pâle
répétition à côté de ce que l'on fait ce
que l'on va alors justement il ya
plusieurs étapes donc oulédi london
bridge is down au jour de la mort
d'elizabeth ii ces mots sur le signal
que la reine d angleterre nous a quittés
mais il ya un instant de suite le
secrétaire privé d'elizabeth ii appelle
ensuite le premier ministre britannique
qui prévient et aux dirigeants du
royaume aux fonctionnaires et membres du
gouvernement étape 3 les chefs d'état du
monde entier sont ensuite également
formé donc tout emmanuel macron est
informée on l'a vu réagit d'abord les
pays du commonwealth et puis des chefs
d'état du monde entier pour qu'ils
puissent organiser leur agenda donc
probablement que l'elysée lui c'est déjà
le palais de l'elysée c'est déjà la date
qui a été retenue pour les obsèques
alors ensuite à la famille royale qui
publie une notification officielle pour
communiquer auprès du peuple britannique
et du reste du monde donc d'abord on
fait et président ensuite voilà le reste
du monde une fois les drapeaux mis en
berne au royaume des buts donc débutera
une période de douze jours de deuil
national donc si ce we did voilà
peut-être catane en exemple les
dimanches sens été décrétée le 12 mars
et ils se seraient 12 que ben la voilà à
partir de là la famille royale annoncera
la date des obsèques de la reine qui
devrait se tenir dix jours exactement ce
que vous avez dit après le mais là ce
sera onze ou douze jours c'est ce qui à
moins qu'il ne décide de le faire un
dimanche serait fort étonnant mais le
premier ministre rencontrera dès lors le
nouveau roi sas est prévue demain à 8
heures précises donc charme s'adressera
à la nation voilà c'est demain on va
assister à ce qu'on appelle la propre a
sion donc on va officiellement là les
chambres vont officiellement reconnaître
charles a comme étant désormais leur
nouveau roi y règnera on le sait sous le
nom de charles iii on est jamais caché
et pendant ce temps là sera mis alors en
écosse l'opération unicorn que l'on
pourrait qualifier d' opération un peu
me cornyn qui va être le fait de
rapatrier la dépouille et on il
semblerait que ce soit à bord du train
alors de langlade de l'halloween charles
sera proclamé officiellement que le
lendemain oui voilà oui voila voila 10
heures du matin oui le même jour le
parlement britannique sera suspendu
ensuite sur le demande angie plus de la
dépouille de la reine devra reposer à
buckingham palace
alors elle l'a quand même est décédé en
écosse il semblerait d'après les
informations que d'abord la dépouille
qui de balmoral qui est son château
privé sa résidence privée pour rejoindre
le palais officiels qui s'appelle
holyroodhouse donc le la dépouille va
quitter pour hollywood house ou voilà où
personne ne va dans le fond pouvoir se
recueillir pendant ce temps là une messe
va être donnée en la cathédrale saint
gilles qui est la plus grande chorale
décosse et quelques heures plus tard la
dépouille va être affrétés à bord du
train royal eh ben on le sait que depuis
1952 la locomotive royal n'a plus n'a
plus tracts et de voitures funèbre s'est
refait 70e pourtant vous avez dit que
c'était s'est adressé non ils ont
annoncé la mort des abeilles de toul est
président est-ce que sur emmanuel
m'accompagner laisse que des anciens
présidents ou y aller ce que nicolas
sarkozy j'ai vu qu'ils avaient faim un
long hommage à elizabeth ii il va y
aller forcément le monde ancien prêtre
se manifester maintenant il faut bien se
dire que c'est un tout petit peu plus de
2000 places que peut accueillir
westminster abbey donc on va pouvoir
accueillir tout le monde non plus
d'accord alors qu'en revanche pour le
couronne miss moss selon l'ancien
président français c'est pas sûr qu'il
soit ou non le temps ça président
français nous l'at je ne pense pas parce
qu'il ya tellement tellement d'autorité
qui doivent être représentés et
simplement on rappelle que elizabeth ii
était chef de l'église anglicane ce qui
fait aussi que l'église va être
fortement représentée aux curieux que
2000 personnes en 2000 invités plus ou
moins que 2000 même puisqu'on estime le
corps ecclésiastique donc l'ensemble
archevêque des évêques sous la haute
autorité de l'archevêque de canterbury
qu'est le primat de toute l'angleterre
là déjà ça va aussi être assez somptueux
on aura la pression à ses relents bien
le jour des obsèques tout est parfait
mais tout simplement sera ont lieu en
l'abbaye de westminster oui voilà deux
minutes de silence ont suivi à travers
tout le royaume deux minutes dans ses
seins oui absolument et vous nous l'avez
dit est ce que c'est vrai que ça
interpelle énormément nous donc là
partir de demain donc quoi vous tenir là
les restaurants sont fermés je ne pense
pas que les restaurants vont être fermés
je crois vraiment les institutions
publiques quant à ouvrir non je ne pense
pas de restaurant uniquement le jour des
funérailles le mans pour les restaurants
pour tout ce qui est privé on rappelle
quand même que l'angleterre est en train
de traverser une crise économique sans
précédent donc voilà c'est pas non plus
c'est pas non plus voilà vous allez y
aller vous nom en angleterre non j'ai je
fais le choix j'ai fait le choix avec
vos équipes et leurs séries de rester
ici pour voilà pour pouvoir mieux
commenté ici tout ce qui se passe là bas
parce qu'en même temps la presse va pas
vraiment être autorisés non plus à
pénétrer dans ces lieux là même au sein
même de l'abbaye de westminster seule la
bbc est vraiment autorisé à
retransmettre donc seul vraiment
quelques journalistes triés sur le volet
à créditer purement anglais vont
vraiment pouvoir approcher ces lieux là
il va y aller dans 10 jours en or pour
les funérailles sa c2 d'ores et déjà
convaincu on peut dire peut-être aussi
que la dépouille va être exposé en tout
cas le cercueil va être ouvert à la
population va être accessible ce serait
plus correct à la population entre 3 à 5
jours pendant vingt trois heures par
jour alors aujourd'hui royaume uni c'est
le peuple il est comment ils sont ici et
là on peut aimer la reine elizabeth ii
va aimer c'est au-delà c'est allez
adorer à une icône hic elle est plus
marilyn que marilyn année est les
célébrissimes année des mails adoré
vraiment elizabeth ii allez adorer donc
là ces systèmes oui c'est une population
qui est en deuil qui est triste ils sont
et ceux de charles arrive comme au rugby
ils sont ils n'ont pas le choix cela
même archi dont il aime beaucoup moi et
mes qu'il sa bête de a maintenant il est
apprécié et célérité le mieux préparé du
monde de charette je n'ai aucun doute
sur le fait que ce sera un bon mois
maintenant les rapports entre mère et
fils on était voilà où le un certain
moment on sait que lisabeth 2 n'a pas
toujours apprécié mais la façon de chars
lourds tous de s'exprimer d'ailleurs
elle va l'être redouté
maintenant je m'adresse à vous parce que
vous êtes vraiment une figure de tpm
paix une figure de ces huit maintenant
quand la reine elizabeth ii n'a été mois
sur moi ça m'a fait de la peine mais bon
voilà je suis pas tellement si le règne
d'elizabeth ii suivi grâce à vous j'ai
tout de suite pensé à vous et d'ailleurs
tous les fans de l'émission on dit
bertrand deckers doit être à dépité
bertrand cantat a appris la mort de la
reine elizabeth tulle après qu'est leur
toit bah moi je l'aï appris en grand en
même temps qu enfin voila depuis 16h10
je sais que voilà que ça va être
annoncée d'une minute à l'autre mais je
vous avoue que j'avais encore quand même
eu un petit espoir et j'ai vu que
c'était voilà j'étais vraiment ici déjà
en loge maquillage quand on m'a dit
quand le communiqué vient vraiment tombé
voilà et vos équipes savent que voilà
voilà j'ai été agi parce que forcément
parce que bon je connais il y avait de
mieux que ceux des membres de ma propre
famille de la pression parfois que je
vis avec elizabeth ii à tel point je
vois là bas vous le savez je suis venu
en parler de nombreuses de nombreuses
fois et pour moi c'est une figure qui
représente à peu toutes les granits
l'angleterre les deux filles une granit
platine mais depuis la grand maman me
faisait faire ces prochains jours ce que
vous avez de déborder vous avez ce oui
c'est vrai ces prochains jours mais oui
je vais été recouvrés monde est là toute
façon vous êtes toujours le bienvenu
c'est merci en tout cas